disaster after disaster on Sunday a 6.3
magnitude earthquake struck part of the
Northwestern Herod province of
Afghanistan that came a week after
entire Villages were flattened by two
Quakes thousands more are now
homeless I was sitting with my sons and
daughters when suddenly the roof
trembled and we were all trapped under
it people took us out of the rubble but
my 15-year-old daughter died my hand
fractured and my back and leg are also
hurt I request the government to build
us houses because the winter here is
very harsh this place has a lot of
problems and severe
cold about oneir of people in
Afghanistan didn't have the food they
need even before the Quake struck those
who survived are now living in tents
like this but winter is coming and
they're worried they won't be enough to
get them
through the wind here will ruin the
tents we must must build a house winter
here is very harsh it rains and snows a
lot and the wind here is Extreme you
can't leave in a tent
here Aid groups say the earthquakes
destroyed several Villages and affected
nearly 45,000 people they struck during
the daytime when many men were working
Outdoors un officials say more than 90%
of those killed were women and
children we were all sitting when the
earthquake hit the roof collapsed on us
I was holding Safa my six-year-old
sister when the roof collapsed she was
screaming Safa died my sister is
murdered my dearest Safa is gone
Afghanistan is one of the poorest
countries in the world mudre homes like
this weren't enough to withstand the
earthquakes little is left of the
villages in this region and funerals are
being held among the
devastation r Al
Jaz make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz